We're continuing our partnership with learn liberty today and joining me is the
former president of the Hclu,
a board member for fire epic and the Heterodox Academy of Professor at New York
Law School and author of the new book hate why we should resist it with free
speech,
not censorship,
navy and stress and welcome to the Rubin report.
Right to be here Dave.
So I have to tell you when I was reading through your bio and looking at all the
boards you've sat on and head of the Aclu and all that,
I don't know that anyone has ever been more of sort of a perfect prime guests to
sit in that chair and my prior book defending pornography,
I that caught your attention.
We can get into that too.
But really your,
your life's work is sort of exactly why I do this show.
And I know I'm setting you up now with a very,
you know,
high bar here but,
but this is what it's all about.
Thank you so much and thank you for your ardent defense of liberty that that is
the most important value for me.
And when people ask me what my politics are,
I usually say I care more about my civil libertarian beliefs than I care about
partisan political beliefs.
And one of the things that's true for the Aclu as well as for me as an
individual,
is not taking per say,
across the board positions on any candidate official party or group,
but judging on an issue by issue basis and issuing PR criticism or uh,
or praise on an issue by issue basis.
And there's not a single party or candidate or official that it hasn't earned
some praise and some criticism on some important civil liberties issues.
So looking at the glass half full as an activist,
I always do that.
There's nobody with whom I don't share some really strong convictions,
which is very nice.
Now it's also true that there is nobody with whom I don't have some strong
disagreements,
but I'm used to therefore having a positive relationship across ideological
divides.
And,
and the absence of that or the fading of that in today's climate is very
bothersome.
Yeah.
All right.
What a great place to start this conversation then.
So as you've seen that fail,
that fade in society,
do you have a couple of markers or moments where you started to really see it or
has it just been a slow slide into wherever it seems that we're at at the
moment?
That's a really good question Dave.
And I'm sure some sociologists have probably analyze it more.
Exactly.
Um,
my impression is at least on issues,
let's stay with issues of free speech.
Uh,
my strong impression is that there started to be a real breaking point in around
2015.
Uh,
I think that's when we had the Ferguson
riots and demonstrations and protests around the country.
And I am completely sympathetic to that cause believe me,
abuses in the criminal justice system.
I have been on my radar screen and the ACO use for ever,
uh,
way back in the dark ages or some would say that great ages of the I,
I meant only in the sense of old and it wasn't a a stigmatizing reference,
but the Reagan administration,
I used to debate his attorney,
General Ed Meese on proposition such as is the criminal justice system,
racially discriminatory.
So the,
and I was taking the yes,
possession.
So the fact that we have this outpouring in support of social justice and racial
justice and,
uh,
immigrants rights and antisexual violence,
all of that is wonderful.
But starting several years ago,
it started to seem more and more that advocates of these causes began to see
free speech as their enemy rather than what I know it to be,
which is their time tested essential ally.
Uh,
so there was this pitting of liberty against equality of civil rights,
against civil liberties.
And as I say that,
I realized that it was the second time that had happened in my adult lifetime.
The first time that,
uh,
that happened very strongly was in the late 1980s,
early 1990s,
which was the first time that hate speech codes were proposed on college
campuses.
The first time,
uh,
we started seeing criticism of what was called political correctness.
And then too,
especially law professors were arguing very strongly that you have to choose,
you can't have both liberty and equality.
And that's anathema to my own beliefs and experience.
And that's kind of where we're at right now.
That seems to be where this argument is boiled down to.
So before we unpack all of that stuff,
how did you get involved in this?
What was it about your education or your upbringing or whatever else that made
you care about free speech,
civil liberties,
everything else that you've just mentioned to you?
As far back as I can remember,
I have been in favor of individual liberty and resisting anybody who tried to
encroach on my liberty or that of anybody else's.
So long before I had the terminology,
I resisted my parents,
authoritarianism,
my school teachers,
authoritarianism.
Uh,
I was kind of a contrarian.
I would always like to see a different perspective.
And I remember being very puzzled as a fairly young student.
Maybe I was about 10 or 11 years old and a teacher said to me,
oh no dean,
why do you always have to defend the underdog?
And she said it as a criticism and to me it was,
well,
they're the ones that need the defense.
I have also always valued freedom of speech for ideas that I disagree with.
So I remember I was in college,
uh,
from 1968 to 1972 I'm very involved in the movement against the Vietnam War,
movements for reproductive freedom.
That was before the Supreme Court had decided Roe v Wade again,
that really dark ages.
Um,
but I also always defended freedom for people who disagreed with me.
So I would have lot big arguments,
uh,
with members of SDS,
students for Democratic Society,
very radical organization that wanted to shout down certain speakers that were
in favor of the Vietnam war administration officials and so forth.
And while I disagreed with the points of view of those speakers,
I didn't believe it that they should,
that we should be denying them a podium.
So as far back as I remember,
I've been,
um,
uh,
a cared much more about freedom in part because I do see that as the essential
means to advance whatever other cause is dear to you.
It's hard to defend the people that you don't like,
isn't it?
It seems to me that that's the one we're forgetting these days.
Like everyone screams about free speech all the time.
The second someone says they don't like,
then they kind of get quiet real quick.
Well,
so I was shortly after I graduated from law school,
uh,
the ACL.
Ooh.
And I was not involved at the national level at all at that point.
But the ACLU got involved in the infamous or famous Skokie case and that was
like a real litmus test.
I assume most viewers know what that is,
but for those who might not,
in 1977,
the ACLU came to the defense of the free speech rights of a group of neo Nazis
who wanted to demonstrate in Skokie,
Illinois,
a suburb of Chicago that had a large Jewish population and a large population of
Holocaust survivors and many members of the ACL,
you even this stalwart free speech organization,
uh,
loss,
we lost about 15% of our members who said,
we really defend free speech.
But this is the one exception we want to make for this absolutely apart speech.
Now my father is a holocaust survivor.
I have to say was sadly,
he died.
But,
um,
it wasn't even an issue for me.
I have to tell you,
Dave,
and it's coming back to your question,
because you said something about how does it feel to defend people that you
disagree with.
And to me,
I'm never defending them.
I'm never defending their ideas.
I'm never defending.
What did they say?
I am defending the principle that government should not have power to silence
speech just because the majority of the public,
even the vast majority of the public low despises the idea that the speech is
conveying.
Yeah.
So that's incredible.
Obviously I know the Skokie case well,
and I'm sure many much of my audiences,
I didn't realize 15% did you say 50% of the membership of ACL EU members.
That's a massive name.
So,
and,
and you know,
so the ACLU really put its money where its mouth is.
It was a tremendous financial hit.
A and there was a lot of negative press.
Now,
in fairness,
a fairly soon after that they ACL,
Ooh,
began to recoup members.
Maybe not necessarily the same people.
In fact,
other people who wrote in and said,
we see that you really are neutral aid,
defending civil liberties even for people that are anti civil air raise
themselves.
Now,
that said,
I have to tell you,
almost every time I give a speech anywhere,
people will come up to me and say,
I was an ACL EU member,
but I quit over Skokie and a Raa nigher who was the executive director at the
time.
And interestingly enough himself,
a Holocaust survivor.
He was born in Berlin.
His,
um,
extended family was completely exterminated by the Nazis.
He and his immediate family escaped.
And,
uh,
and he wrote a wonderful book about it afterwards called defending my enemy,
which I quote in my book.
Uh,
and we can talk about how that might seem paradoxical,
but it's,
it's really not.
But anyway,
in this context,
I brought him up because he said to me,
Nadine,
if every person who said they left the ACLU over Skokie really had been a
member,
we would have been the largest organization in the world game.
If I can just follow up on that.
It's not just an abstract principle because you can really see how the principal
has concrete ramifications for exactly the opposite ideas.
So in our briefs,
in the Skokie case,
we pointed out that the arguments that were being made to justify suppressing
the Nazis,
namely that their ideas were offensive and insulting and threatening and seen as
dangerous to the Jews and the Holocaust survivors in Skokie.
That was exactly the same set of arguments that was made not that much earlier
in 1968 when Martin Luther King was trying to demonstrate in Cicero,
Illinois,
the very same state,
but with a very different population that saw his ideas as threatening and
dangerous and subversive,
offensive and insulting.
This is where this weird,
subjective nature of this comes in,
which is why you've said several times now you're defending the principal,
not the person,
and that that of course is the,
is the key to this whole,
but we've been pushed
into this place these days where it seems like there's a large set of people or
certainly a set of very loud people who think that speech is violence.
It ain't violence.
Well,
I suppose speech could advocate violence,
it could incite violence,
it could threaten violence.
So do you,
so do you agree with where we have the law is now in terms of you can't directly
insight and that sort of thing.
Do you think all those laws are are just inappropriate?
Absolutely.
And I have to say,
even though I've been teaching constitutional law,
the First Amendment for decades,
the process of writing this book and thinking about it and even more focused
fashion really increased my respect for us law.
And I really think that for many people,
if they would just understand what the law actually provides,
they would be much more supportive of freedom of speech because it is much more
nuanced and much more common sensical then is often misdescribe when people say
either,
Oh,
hate speech is not free speech.
We heard here that a lot,
including when you were at the University of New Hampshire.
We are in that a lot.
Right?
Um,
and then conversely,
people will say,
Oh,
hate speech is protected.
And neither generalization is correct.
Yes.
I,
this fact that speech has a hateful or hated message idea or content can never
be a justification for censoring it.
But if in a particular context,
a hateful message along with any other message,
uh,
directly causes certain serious,
specific imminent harm and there's no way to avert that harm other than
punishing the speech,
then the speech can and should be punished.
And common examples that satisfy that standard are intentional incitement of
imminent violence,
a genuine threat that instills fear that you're going to be subject to violence.
Um,
uh,
another example is a hate crime and that is,
it's,
it's a little bit different in the sense that a n I'm going so much into my
constitutional it,
no,
we're going into the weeds with that,
but that's good.
That's good.
Okay.
So if I can say there is no term hate speech and that was a point that you made
in your University of New Hampshire.
They said that it's a fact,
right?
And,
and it's a fact that is subscribed to by every single supreme court justice
across the ideological spectrum,
you know,
from Ginsburg and Sotomayor on the left to Alito and Gorsuch and Scalia on the
right.
And I think that's a very,
very important point there for all of their ideological differences on so many
issues that so many justices,
every justice in modern history has subscribed to this.
And I wish that people across the ideological spectrum in other branches of
government and the general public which share that unanimity because no matter
who you are,
no matter what you believe,
you really have a stake in denying the government and the majority of,
of people that wield power,
uh,
taking away from you the choice about which views you will express or listened
to or refute.
So in that University of New Hampshire speech that I know you watched when,
when I was saying there,
you know,
hate speech is not real.
Obviously I was making the distinction between the direct call to violence,
which I actually said,
unless it's a direct call to balance,
but hate speech in and of itself is,
is nothing.
It's not a,
it's not a thing you can say mean things.
I would prefer you don't.
We wish we could all be nice to each other and say lovely things.
I use pronouns the way people want it and all of those things.
But you can't have the government doing it.
Is there anything else that I should have added in that,
that perhaps could have gotten those young people to uh,
listen to that they were disposed not to listen,
but for,
there were obviously some open minded people in the audience.
And those are the ones that you're,
I mean,
the hecklers,
I think we're,
we're not Jen,
they didn't seem genuinely interested in,
in hearing you out,
but have many other people.
They're dead.
And the other point that,
that I would make strategically,
Dave and I already did it and pointing out the Martin Luther King counterpart to
the Nazis is I always tried to give an example where I an idea that you happen
to support that the person I'm talking to it really supports would be threatened
if we gave that power to the government.
So,
uh,
for that,
that audience where you had people chanting black lives matter,
I would have pointed out how many government officials now are saying black
lives matter advocacy should be treated as hate speech.
Uh,
that even saying that black lives matters should be treated as a hate group.
the southern poverty law center,
which monitors hate groups has been lobbied to treat black lives matter as such.
And so then you had to say to people,
you,
you have to understand that it's not your values that are going to be
implemented by the enforcing officials across the country.
And if we have this loose,
nebulous concept,
I mean hate is an emotion.
It's inherently subjective.
What one person considers hateful,
somebody else cherishes.
Yeah.
So you mentioned the southern poverty law center.
I don't want to get you in any hot water here,
but they to me,
strike me as an organization that has completely,
completely with almost no reservation.
Can I say this gone off the rails.
But they have,
you know,
between now they just,
just in this last week they,
they lost this lawsuit.
Margin wise is getting a three point $3 million settlement,
but they had an eye on her cle and Bridgette Gabriel and several people who I've
had
on the show who I think are,
are wonderful people,
uh,
on their hate list.
They just put up a,
uh,
an article about the evils of Prager university and called me out by name.
What am I to make of the shifting of traditionally organizations that were doing
good work into becoming what I would say are really far left advocacy groups
instead of maybe the original mission statement.
Would
I think that was a fair assessment,
just not knowledgeable enough about,
um,
the instances that you,
so I'll go back to something I said at the beginning,
which is I don't endorse or criticize any organization across the board.
I look at it issue by issue and I think they,
uh,
southern poverty law center has done a lot of good work on issues that,
that I care about,
including a freedom of speech on campus.
And they definitely oppose censorship are including of hate speech.
I testified with a leader of the SPLC,
uh,
before,
Congress,
uh,
last year and completely opposed to censorship,
completely supporting counter speech.
And in fact,
the SPLC put out a wonderful guide for college students at the beginning of the
last academic year urging them,
uh,
when a white supremacist recruiters are coming to campus not to engage in
disruption,
not try to censor them or just shout them down,
but to ignore them.
And I thought that was right,
not only in principle,
but also as a matter of strategy because you're just playing into their tactics.
Now,
does that mean that every single thing they've done is,
is,
is praiseworthy?
I doubt it.
I think even the ACLU is not a above
criticism.
Yeah.
So I know when,
when they sent over some notes about what w what we potentially could talk about
in your book and everything else.
Um,
so because you did watch that University of New Hampshire thing,
there's a moment where a girl that was challenged me kept implying that it was
free speech,
sort of that led to the Holocaust,
that it was this,
that they allowed incitement.
And that that's what led to it.
Now,
my basic argument was the more speech there is,
the more we can allow sunlight to disinfect bad ideas.
But I think perhaps I could have been a little more forceful there.
If you were standing next to me when we were doing this,
what,
what would you have been saying in my ear to that argument that if we just keep
letting people say all these awful things that it can lead to awful things and
awful things obviously have happened throughout the course of you.
Yeah,
I have a lot of answers,
but let me start with the one that is most specific to the Holocaust.
And again,
I have a personal stake and I know you also lost relatives in the Holocaust off
for me.
My father fortunately survived,
but he was in a concentration camp and suffered grievously doing forced labor
and in fact was scheduled to be sterilized and then was liberated by the u s
military one day before.
So,
you know,
I almost had my life exterminated before it began.
I have no love lost for the Nazis.
In fact,
there was,
uh,
there were hate speech laws in the Weimar Republic,
Drury Inn,
which is,
uh,
Germany where Hitler rose to power.
And the hate speech laws were very similar to the ones that exist in Germany and
other countries today.
They were very strictly enforced.
Nazis were prosecuted and convicted repeatedly and gas what?
They loved it,
it was a huge propaganda opportunity for them.
They gained attention and support that they otherwise never would have had.
Just like the Neo Nazis in Skokie,
all those years later,
nobody would have heard of them if we adjust,
allowed them to have their miserable little march for the 20 minutes to 30
minutes they were seeking to march instead of becomes two years' worth of
worldwide attention.
Now,
the problem in Nazi in Pre Nazi Germany was that there was no protection against
violence that the Nazis were engaging in.
Uh,
so,
uh,
their political opponents as well as Jews and others were subject literally to
physical assaults and even murder without any sufficient protection or
punishment.
So,
uh,
the other point I would make is that,
um,
those of us who are minorities and Jews are a tiny minority in this country and
around the world is specially depend on freedom of speech because by definition
we're never going to have majority power.
So all we have to depend on,
uh,
to limit the majority from trampling on our rights is freedom of speech to
protest,
uh,
the First Amendment right of association,
to the right to petition the government for redress of grievances are Jonathan
route.
She had great gay rights advocate who my quota.
My work makes the same point about,
you know,
as a member of sexual orientation,
minority,
all minorities especially depend on free speech.
Uh,
I quote all a lot of civil rights leaders,
um,
in my book,
Martin Luther King,
the Naacp,
uh,
throughout the civil rights movement were completely opposed to censorship
including hate speech laws in part because their speech was viewed as hated and
even hateful and certainly dangerous.
How concerned are you,
you about
self censorship?
Not,
not the government doing it,
but what I see more as the sort of the low level war right now,
which is just the emails that I get every day about people afraid to speak up at
work.
People are afraid to speak up at college.
People literally afraid to speak up in their own homes because they've been so
crushed by political correctness.
They don't want to start fights with loved ones.
It's,
it's a serious problem and I have to say it's a difficult problem because to
some extent the point of counter speech,
which I advocate,
and by the way,
that's a legal listic way of saying anything you disagree with.
You just re rather than trying to squelch it,
stopping that expression from coming out,
you respond to it,
you debate it,
you try to persuade you could Joel,
so that's countering an idea you dislike with your own speech.
To some extent,
the goal of counter speech is to chill certain speech and a certain ideas,
right?
You want to dissuade somebody from adhering to white supremacist views.
You don't see it as bad if they self sensor,
right?
But when does that persuasion crossed the line into bullying or Harrison?
I think that's a very important and difficult issue,
which was discussed very extensively in the famous John Stuart Mill Essay on
liberty of many people who haven't recently read.
It would be surprised as I was because I hadn't read it for a few years on my
travels and somebody reminded me that his main focus there was not on direct
government coercion,
but rather on the social pressure that is exerted by colleagues,
peers,
civil society,
and in this country.
On the one hand,
I'm very glad that there is such a robust civil society,
condemnation of racist tweets by Roseanne Barr to site a fairly recent example.
On the other hand,
I'm afraid of the mob,
um,
ruthlessly punishing somebody who may have just said something that's
insensitive.
Uh,
and,
and I'm concerned about that,
David.
Not only because I don't want to,
um,
you know,
the mob is no more appealing as a force that drives certain ideas out of
existence than the government is.
But I'm also concerned from the point of view of educating and persuading.
And,
you know,
I've met people that have been not only members,
but leaders of hate groups who have come to see that they were wrong,
who have come to,
um,
realize that all of us are equal and entitled to equal dignity and equal rights.
And they've reputed they're formerly discriminatory ideas and they didn't come
to that change by being denounced as racists,
much less as would happen in Europe by being imprisoned as,
as racist.
So if our goal truly is to,
um,
gain more support on the part of more people for the ideals of liberty and
justice and human rights and equality and dignity for all,
I think we don't do it by,
by shouting them down.
So it's a strategic question as well as a PR,
a principled question.
Yeah.
Is that just one of those things where it's like in the moment that we live in,
we often don't live up to our ideals in the best way possible because you
referenced being constitutional law professor and I've got the declaration of
independence and the constitution framed right in that room right over there.
And it's like these guys that were writing these incredible documents that have
given more freedom to more people than ever in the history of the world.
Well some of them were slave owners and,
and plenty of other things and probably womanizers and whatever.
And it's like,
but yet they were writing the things that freed us,
which is an incredible,
and that's just a little something about being human.
And,
and I think it ties back to to some of our earlier conversation that um,
so much of what passes as debate such as your hecklers at the University of New
Hampshire is not genuinely engaged in really trying to relate to you as a full
fledged human being with whom they might.
I have absolutely no doubt based on my experience that there are no two people
in the world who won't have at least some strong common concern,
some idea that they are passion that they both deeply care about and are
committed to and,
and some that they deeply disagree about.
And I think it's not,
it's really important not to paper over the disagreements.
I think we should discuss them and hash them out,
but I think we can do that more constructively and effectively if we also find
what we have in common and and relate to each other in,
in a holistic way.